am i the [ __ ] for telling my extended
family how many men roughly my sister
has slept with after she outed our
youngest brother as a virgin wow okay
all right
oh my gosh she was like an ab
conversation she had to see her wait she
said z yeah z so i responded by saying
how she slept with well over a hundred
men while she was in college and that
since everyone in the family knows that
knows this it's not a big deal right
[Applause]
turns out spicy her husband didn't know
this
oh
extra spicy
i genuinely assumed he must have known
no why would he know
who would admit to that first of all
i don't know i mean you wouldn't tell
your husband how many people no no
no i did oh
future husband
never would i do something like that i
don't want to know his numbers no you
know that's not the thing that we
discussed tip leave your honesty over
there
[Music]
hi welcome back to another episode of
big mood
oh my god we missed you so much i feel
like we haven't filmed in so long but i
mean we have we released just fine yeah
i just missed them that's all uh we're
missing a couple members today because
they went and decided to live far yeah
in other states rude but we have an
incredible beautiful sexy gorgeous tall
guest today tell me who you are baby i'm
nikki blaze
here
also for our listeners hi it's me gina
and then and tiff
so you guys are going to hear a bunch of
like different noises some cat meows
baby screaming sometimes it synchronizes
it's weird
they're getting along just fine okay so
today i'm actually really excited about
this episode because like i don't know
why we didn't do this sooner i feel like
it's really fun we we uh we browsed
reddit on the subreddit called am i the
[ __ ] and we're gonna read these
stories of people asking and explaining
their stories and asking the public am i
the [ __ ] for doing this and we're
gonna weigh in on it too
and i found a few
and the fun thing about these is like at
first it sounds like oh no that's a
clear-cut answer but then they explained
themselves yeah and you're like oh oh
these people actually get a chance to
explain themselves
that normally never gets subreddit yeah
that's why it is interesting really fun
yeah it's really fun so i pulled up a
few
and let's jump into it and then i'm
gonna we're also gonna read the comments
of people and see if they agree or not
too okay
the first one is
am i the [ __ ] for telling my
boyfriend's friends i make twice what he
does when they called me a gold digg and
he didn't defend me
immediate not the ass yeah like i'm on
immediately whatever yeah on her side
right
so here's a story
i'm gonna try to make it quick yeah all
right so
i'm in a relationship with a guy who
also works in tech he makes sixty eight
thousand dollars i make a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars
i am a mechanical engineer at a robotic
startup he works at a more stable job
programming at a large company he
brought me to meet his friends at a
party and they asked the but asked me
about myself his friends mostly work in
tech 2 and talked about themselves in
terms of their jobs i told them i'm a
hiker i do archery i love road trips and
camping and riding bikes basically
talking about my hobbies because work is
just a way to get paid to do the [ __ ]
that i love
it's not how i define myself and it
doesn't come to mind when someone wants
it wants me to tell them about myself
so one of his friends asked about work
and i said oh gosh i don't talk about
work at a party i spent my whole day
sweating my ass off in a 95 degree heat
trying to replace this busted-ass motor
just to find a replacement part was also
[ __ ] okay she's a mechanical engineer
hands-on i wasn't lying or trying to
downplay that i have a good job that
really is how i spent my day and i
wasn't in the mood to talk shop at a
party some other conversations came up
casually that probably also made me seem
poorer like me saying that car
dealership repairs were rip-off and
telling my boyfriend that my childhood
neighbor's trailer caught on fire and i
was gonna visit and help her out i
wasn't doing it on purpose it got later
in the night everyone was getting
drunker and some of his friends not the
close ones were making jokes about me
growing up in a trailer and being a gold
digger i'm sorry
okay let's finish the story before we
that's rude i'm personally offended
because i did grow up in a trailer park
mm-hmm until i was eight years you were
just fine now and i turned out just
they're they were saying some really
misogynistic [ __ ] honestly since they
don't even know me and seem to just
assume all girls are gold diggers he
didn't say anything
yikes he later said it was because he'd
smoke weed and gets quiet and was
trouble has trouble carrying on a
conversation when he's high but
regardless i felt hurt he didn't say
anything i got irritated with his
friends and asked now why the hell would
you say that when i make twice what he
does
his friends went quiet for a second and
i continued saying there ain't no gold
to dig here not with him or anyone at
this party so do y'all think i'm cheap
or do y'all think i'm stupid
my boyfriend wanted me to leave or my
boyfriend wanted to leave the party
shortly after and he was pretty upset
with me for telling everyone i make
twice what he does
i said i would have held my tongue if he
checked his friends himself but he
didn't say anything so i wasn't about to
let them talk to me like that
he said it was humiliating and now
everyone thinks i'm a [ __ ] and i
flippantly said at least they know i'm a
rich [ __ ]
yeah i love her
he was angry i embarrassed him when i
spoke up i was angry i had to say
anything at all because his friends were
talking [ __ ] so it should be on him to
check them
stuff is still tense am i the [ __ ] oh
absolutely not first and foremost why
the
why did anybody think that making 68 000
a year was something to be like bragging
about well did they know his income i
don't think they knew his income so okay
so nobody knows but he's an engineer so
she's not talking about it yeah just the
assumption right based off of look if
you're making money you're making money
more props to you it doesn't really
matter how much you make in you're
making bread but in this scenario it's
like the audacity yeah the audacity that
you're going to sit here and just assume
that you're playing to her face
yeah
to her
they must have been really dope like i
hope they were really drunk and they're
not just [ __ ] like that naturally
and casually yeah i somebody correct me
but i just stumbled across on the
internet not that long ago where the
like term gold digger even came from it
was like back in the day when pretty
much women were marrying um
men security yeah for security and then
when it didn't work out like they were
able to sue them because pretty much
they wasted their time in their youth
that's kind of where it came from and
then there was a point in time where
women just were kind of doing this you
know uh there really wasn't any
reasoning behind it no one was cheating
they just like made up these stories and
then that's where like the gold they run
away with the money yeah like the gold
digger phrase came from so it did root
there is a pass with that saying
but this is 2022 yeah really what are we
doing what are we doing here for anyone
to have the cojones to tell someone
they're a gold digger like you not even
the richest person in the room would
even call someone a girl yeah
they don't care
yeah find it so funny that a lot of men
are like complaining and crying about
gold diggers when they have no gold
themselves
like why why are you complaining about a
problem that's not yours yeah
that's a red pill stuff yeah if you're
dating someone and someone else speaks
on your partner
like just
going at their character
wouldn't you put it upon yourself to
address the situation so that your
partner wouldn't have to defend
themselves for sure
it sucks that she had to speak up
because yeah no he should have said
something he's a little bit a thousand
percent but then also like he says he
was high
let's give him a tiny bit of benefit of
the doubt where it's like all right fine
okay you guys you can't like not
everyone has the same experience
especially when they're under the
influence of things like okay but same
the reason why i'm kind of like giving a
little bit of benefit of doubt to their
friends too because i'm like i hope they
were really drunk to say some some [ __ ]
like this especially to her face because
but he's like a normal sense to be an
[ __ ] man for sure i totally agree but
i feel like i'm the type of person
that's like okay you kind of get like a
tiny like a smidgen of a pass because
you were under the influence of some
other [ __ ] my cat's destroying the set
i'm so sorry but okay so say we give him
the benefit of the doubt yeah then that
means that he can't be mad at her right
now exactly that i see why fully agree
oh i know why because it's a it's a stab
at his you go for sure yeah but it's
like
kitty nibbler's giving us two cents yeah
come here come here is he an [ __ ] is
she an [ __ ] she's on [ __ ] right i
don't think she's an [ __ ] no so he
why is he angry because the men that
i've dated most of them
they
well a few of them were proud that i
made more money like that probably
they're like yeah that's my girl you
know but this guy's like oh you made me
look like a little [ __ ] ball ball like
um that's his insecurity
that's your problem yeah because if he
was more secure with himself then that
wouldn't really bother him i feel like
that takes like a really mature person
who has their own ego in check yeah
that's a hard thing to do
for both of them yeah could she have
handled the situation differently of
course she could have could he have
handled it differently of course he
could have but now we're in this
situation you was high everybody was
kind of drinking
they attacked your girlfriend that was
an attack yeah
straight up coming at her character
which essentially is talking about your
character too right they're looking down
on your girl
and then you get upset because she had
to defend herself
now
we all know that like she could have
brushed it off or she could have went
about it a different way she could have
easily said like don't worry about my
check i'm fine without throwing him
under the bus yeah which is why he's
upset yeah because there is an art to
talking [ __ ] back without anybody else
becoming involved in the mess yeah but i
mean it's it's understandable totally
why she threw her money at us because
she's like bro you're not gonna say
anything protect me protect your woman
like stand up for me like i need i need
my protector yeah and that's where the
problem is because he she would have
done it differently if he would have had
her back if she felt safe enough in the
relationship yeah exactly she would have
been like man don't worry about you call
me a golden girl you want her babe i'm a
gold digger right like i'm digging all
that gold to where he could have chimed
in and been like
you know like yeah like we know what's
up that's the key yeah the security and
the relationship let's see what the
comments say oh that does suck though
but you know when you're in a good
relationship and you're in a good place
with your partner like
y'all would have had more fun
messing with them yeah then they're
messing with you yeah yeah comment said
not the [ __ ] his friends sound like
those dudes that whine that they can't
get girlfriends think they deserve
supermodels but then are complete
misogynist
boyfriend got his ego bruise and you let
it be known you out earn him he'll get
over it or he's stuck in the patriarchal
idea ideal that the man is supposed to
be the main breadwinner
if he feels that way then go yeah yeah
and and go make more money than her yeah
make more money or date someone who
doesn't make as much money so you feel
more like a man yeah um not the [ __ ]
your boyfriend chooses to hang out with
people who are misogynistic and
judgmental he chooses to stay silent
when they aim their vitrol at you and
then he chooses to direct his anger and
shame at you
refusing to let yourself be treated like
trash when someone shows you who they
are believe them the first time yeah
that is a really that's a really good
point
this is a huge red flag for her
yeah i think so yeah and then also how
he handles conflict especially when he's
he's also in the wrong yeah yeah yeah i
actually want to see if there's anyone
that says she is the [ __ ] and we'll
look at the comments and see if she's
the [ __ ] or not if you know
like like i said i see where he's coming
from and why he's upset
if you're looking at it from that
perspective yeah as far as like your
relationship goes she could have went
about it without throwing him under the
bus but because she was upset with him
that's why she did it that way yeah so i
found one that says you are the [ __ ]
let's see who this guy says
you are the [ __ ] you knew exactly
what you were doing you were directly
asked about your work and you played coy
and guarded around the answer then you
knowingly and purposely made a string of
comments insinuating that you were poor
you say you just happened to do all
these things randomly in secession but
you didn't you did it on purpose you
seemed like you were looking to do this
you're not fooling anyone oh
oh my god wow what is going on wait if
someone could be that like she's [ __ ]
conniving
she's an evil genius evil she knows how
to manipulate people psychologically
like that yeah like the long game like
that for what like for what just just
say i make more than him yeah
but there was no other conversation
about salaries yeah like i can
understand if there was a conversation
initially about salaries because we're
just going on the assumption of how much
an engineer makes because when i heard
68 and then i'm hearing 130. but then
the term gold digger even being brought
up in this conversation doesn't make
sense let's just throw this out there
that no it doesn't make sense these are
just hard-working people yeah maybe it's
the fact that we've been in california
for too long that i'm just like y'all
need each other yeah
that 130 baby his 68 is helping your 130
let's just be honest let's not act like
we rich nobody's rich in this
conversation or in this room
okay
so
it's a little bit like uh but i don't
think i mean
yeah i don't think that's what happened
i'm trying to make it make sense yeah
that guy sounds salty as [ __ ] damn it's
not a girl it could have been a girl is
that a guy who commented that that's a
guy i can see his photos like something
on write accounts you can like i mean i
mean but hey he gave her a lot of credit
he really like even though he's trying
to be like
who hurt him he's trying to be involved
women are so conniving like that but
that's what they can be but then like
he's like that's his first thought but
what i'm saying is like yo he gave her a
ton of props yeah realistically that's a
huge compliment but he thought that she
was so smart
she plotted this whole thing what
happened
wow you really think she's so smart i
love that okay ready for the next one
yeah okay wait but so wait in conclusion
she's not the [ __ ] okay all right
next one i really like this we should do
this more out then this is super fun um
am i the [ __ ] for telling my extended
family how many men roughly my sister
has slept with after she outed our
youngest brother as a virgin wow okay
all right here we go
oh my god she did it it's like an a b
conversation she had to see her wait she
said z yeah z
z plus 24
6 during spring break okay wow so she
told her extended family how many men
her sister has slept with after the
sister outed their younger brother as a
virgin
their youngest brother okay here we go
house jumping is a brother all right
let's see why does it matter okay okay
why should you have to defend him does
he always get bullied okay here we go
okay we had a family dinner this evening
my family has four kids in total okay
there's me my elder sister who's 29 my
younger sister is 24 and my youngest
brother who's 22 okay
extended family attended our family
dinner so all of our significant others
our cousins aunts and uncles etc were
there during the dinner my elder sister
and my youngest brother got into
oh the elders wait oh okay so 29 and 22.
okay so 29 is the eldest one okay
brother's 22. we'll just call him 29 and
20. yeah okay during the dinner my elder
sister 29 and youngest brother 22 got
into a mild disagreement my sister
seemed at least me to be coming across
as very aggressive out of frustration
and losing said argument the two of them
were too absorbed in their argument to
realize the rest of us were getting a
bit fed up eventually my sister got fed
up and said shut up i'm not gonna argue
with a 22 year old virgin
wow
my brother hadn't done any personal
attacks up until that point it was
completely unprovoked i think it might
have been the alcohol as my sister is
mean drunk damn anyways i immediately
told my sister to grow up and they
should make an embarrassment of herself
she replied by saying everyone knows
he's a virgin and she didn't say
anything wrong uh this annoyed me as my
bro definitely has confidence issues and
doesn't need to be made fun of like this
so i responded by saying how she slept
with well over a hundred men while she
was in college and that since everyone
in the family knows that knows this it's
not a big deal right
turns out spicy her husband didn't know
this
oh
extra spicy
i genuinely assumed he must have known
i mean you wouldn't tell your husband
how many people no no
no i did oh
future husband
never would i do something like that i
don't want to know his numbers no you
know that's not the thing that we
discussed tip leave your honesty over
there
you're repulsed by my honesty
so
he left the party angrily saying my
sister misled him about her past
family is blaming me for their marital
problems i refuse to accept i did
anything wrong my sister bullied my
brother in front of everyone all i did
was give her a taste of her own medicine
oh man am i the [ __ ] this is a good
one cause i don't know i feel like she
is and she's not it wasn't her fight
yeah that's why she is it's not her
fight as an older sibling you have to
know when to back out of these damn
situations she's always she's the second
one so the person telling stories the
second yeah yeah so you have
you guys oh you some i love my sister
now okay my sister and i
now get along she is the middle child
there's a sense of entitlement that they
have
and they are the first ones to want to
dead any anything like you you think
you're out of 10 she's out of 38.
that was a 38.
is it necessary no but it's on some
tit-for-tat type stuff
are you the [ __ ] 1 000
anytime you throw somebody's number out
there especially in front of their
partner it doesn't matter that wasn't
your fight yeah do you want to get the
biggest [ __ ] award because you won
you you are the [ __ ] yeah you stopped
and yeah you defended your brother but
did you think that was the best way to
do it
there's an art to fighting yeah you do
look like a [ __ ] though i think there
are lines that you don't cross however
however
i want to say
okay it depends on how well you get
along with your siblings because i have
a sibling i'm like i will throw you
under the bus literally you know what i
mean
so it's like but does that make you an
[ __ ] yeah see yeah yeah that's what
we're doing we're discussing if she's an
[ __ ]
not saying if it's right or wrong we're
just saying are you an [ __ ] if the
brother was the one that said will you
slept with x amount of people including
his fight yeah
girl that was not your battle true yeah
it wasn't her battle that's true that
does okay so what does the comment so
what do you think so the part like i
fully agree that that makes her a major
[ __ ] but then the part that i'm like
well
i can see why she
she isn't one but in my book she's
leaning more heavily on the [ __ ] but
the part that she's not an [ __ ] is
because she's trying to defend her
brother especially because she sees that
he has uh low confidence yeah issues
yeah confidence issues and so she sees
her little brother there drowning she
clearly has some [ __ ] against the older
sisters she's calling her an alcoholic
already
there's already some bad blood there
some resentment so she found her
opportunity to stab yes it makes her an
[ __ ] but i think it makes her with
good intention [ __ ] yeah yeah again
i we're all kind of on the same page
though like we understand what you're
doing yes you're defending your younger
brother but first off there are some
things you don't talk about
i mean in front of the family i just had
a conversation with my sister literally
the other day talking about how
we have to keep our family stuff to our
family and not around the rest of them
because your extended family be the
first ones wanting to watch you fail you
know what they're doing now they are
thriving off of the fact that you all
just opened up your can of worms in
front of everyone else so now they feel
better about all the [ __ ] they got
going on in their family
so no matter what we can have problems
with our siblings
keep that ish at home because you're
gonna know how they knew she stopped
with over a hundred percent yeah
look in college we all know what cousin
is a whole
yeah we all know what hold on
who knows but we all know that maybe she
was uh in one of her drunken um
yeah she's probably bragging yeah but
you know i slept over a hundred oh my
god y'all y'all know you got that hoey
ass friend that low-key brags and then
they found jesus or something or their
husband and changed their ways if you're
thinking of switching birth controls or
maybe trying it for the first time and
you don't know where to start check out
favor favor provides personalized access
to care from the comfort of your home
and delivery to your door in really
discreet packaging on time every time
the service you know and love as the
pill club is now favor favor provides
digital care prescriptions and products
for your well-being with over four
thousand five star reviews favor carries
over 120 fda approved brands and ships
to all 50 states most brands of birth
control are free with insurance or
medicaid otherwise prices start as low
as 6.99 per pack without insurance
that's amazing favor delivers birth
control to your door for free in the
screen packaging along with fun
self-care extras something that a
doctor's office would never do their
licensed medical team is just a text
away to provide you for the care that
you deserve that way you don't have to
go to the doctor's office sign up for
birth control in just five minutes skip
the office visit waiting in line at the
pharmacy and get treated right right now
when you go to hayfavor.com big mood
favor is offering a 10 donation to
bedsider.org for every big mood listener
who becomes a patient your donation will
help low-income individuals get access
to birth control through bedsider.org
that's
h-e-y-f-a-v-o-r dot com big mood to get
your first birth control care package
and donate to help more women in need of
affordable birth control again that's
heyfavor.com big mood you must use a
link to make a donation okay i don't
think i know anyone's number no i don't
think anyone's number other than my
husband yeah
anyone who discusses that unless you're
in high school like oh how many i think
i feel like college is when everyone
kind of maybe has that conversation and
then you get out
that's how i choose to do okay so are we
in ingredients okay she's an [ __ ]
she's an [ __ ] however we have someone
who says she's not reddit says
everyone sucks here
this one yeah yeah so that is an option
esh everyone sucks here didn't know that
one person i didn't know that was an
option yeah okay um one person making
personal attacks doesn't mean someone
else should especially since you weren't
even in the argument to begin with
that's a top comment right uh let's see
second top comment says
oh
you know what have been you know what
would have been really good huh on some
real
like you really want to be that girl
would have went up to my brother
said
hey
remind her that she slept with over 100
people in college
yeah let him say it if you wanted to if
you want to do that also he probably
wouldn't since he has
sometimes you got to hype them up right
you got to go back there yeah yeah let's
get her sure
she's no just say it just don't say just
just say oh you used to be a hoe
i may be a virgin but at least i'm not a
horse
there we go that would have been a
better fight because then it wouldn't
have been a number and then the
husband's not involved yeah see you know
what i'm saying no but then the
husband's like you were a what yeah then
that's his fault don't call me a virgin
then
true see this comment here says she's
not the [ __ ]
they said fire with fire is justified if
the other person is making a claim a
certain [ __ ] behavior is not
asshole-ish if they claim that and then
whine when it comes back to them it just
makes them a blatantly hypocritical
[ __ ]
everyone in this sub likes to spout two
wrongs don't make it right but you are
missing the fact that the sister thinks
this is supposedly acceptable so he's
just returning to her what she thinks is
acceptable conversation topic
yeah i honestly fail to see how that
makes him the [ __ ]
oh so the the person asking is a guy i
thought it was a girl uh i don't know i
think that person is speaking on the
behalf of the brother mm-hmm yeah no
we're talking about uh
the girl who screamed out her sister
yeah with 100 people i think that person
might have misunderstood the assignment
yeah another the second top comment says
not the [ __ ] you were looking out for
your little brother and you fought with
the truth if your sister can't take the
truth she shouldn't dish it out she also
shouldn't have kept it from her husband
for sure that's a i mean i you guys
don't agree but i agree that she should
communicate with her husband about her
sexual past if it's it's important to
him clearly it was important to him yeah
like if it wasn't important and he
didn't care then find whatever yeah but
clearly it was important well they must
have had a conversation about it
if it was that important to him to react
that way and she must have lied about it
i think the biggest thing is the
circumstances that we're under right
there is a lot of people around there's
a lot of friends there's a lot of family
there's this is not just like yeah a
small intimate fight to where you guys
can go hash it out it's one of those
things like oh did you know
like oh you didn't know she was out when
everybody else is like looking at him
like oh yeah we all kind of knew this oh
yeah that's humiliating for them so
with that being said the situation
itself is what makes this worse because
again time in place
did she get you yeah nibbler just uh got
my hair oh i'm sorry no it's okay
but yeah this is a time and place this
this whole situation is a mess yeah the
the oldest sister yeah for calling him a
virgin she's i mean she's a giant bee
for that
because you were losing the fight so you
went for the personal attack but then
the sister stepping in
y'all don't like each other we can see
we can do it you don't like your sister
so just i mean you're an [ __ ] and
just own it yeah i feel like i would
have defended my sister the same way if
it was against like assuming that i
didn't like yeah you know i've done that
before in like family group chats yeah
you know it does make me an [ __ ]
right but sometimes some people deserve
to have an [ __ ] come after me like
some of the taste of their own medicine
hey if you're gonna be an [ __ ] though
you gotta own it don't come asking
people if i'm an [ __ ] and i'd be like
no i defended my brother
she was being she was being an [ __ ] i
was being a bigger one and i won you
gotta just wear it i'm you're not gonna
get sympathy over here
hey you ain't you you said oh fire with
fire gasoline
exactly
she
like the family member that no one likes
do you guys have any of that oh my god i
don't hear about this i mean you come we
all come from like relatively diverse
families honestly i'm not like super
tight with my family like i i was really
close to them when i was younger because
like i had to we're
there
but now as an adult i don't really i'm
not super super super close with most of
my family now i try to keep in touch
here and there with my cousins the ones
that i grew up with because i'm like hey
what happened we just kind of like lost
touch but i don't really like fully i'm
not involved in their lives i like that
to to have opinions about them
on their personal level i don't know if
that makes sense no that does i gotta
really know them know them even though
they're my family like we're not tight
tight i used to be tighter with my
cousins until we realized like our
the adults that's the reason why we're
not tight tight yeah
yeah the adults in these situations are
really like manipulative and like super
vindictive and like use their kids as
pawns you know everything was like oh
well
your
sister was doing this and i heard it
from my dad or you know it's just always
like some adult trying to stir the pot
which is why within like me my sister my
brother we try to keep everything at
home especially now that they have kids
i don't know why these old heads always
got an opinion about everybody else's
kids
but that's what i've learned so when it
comes to family because we've had major
blow ups like this i'm talking about
like
major people getting thrown through
walls
yeah like we had big fights growing up
so that's why it's like look you knew
exactly what you were doing
own it because that right there like if
you come into a situation where you know
you have the ammo and you're sitting on
it which is what she was doing
and you throw it out there you about to
be standing up big chested all of a
sudden like okay now who's going to say
something to me yeah but for real with a
lot of families i feel like everyone's
holding that
like in their back pocket against
everyone mm-hmm dang oh god i have so
many
[Music]
yeah no we've super messed up i can't
believe i just had this conversation
though i was really talking with my
sister about like
my
i don't mind sharing this um my
so my dad had to my dad was supposed to
go to the doctors
and
my uncle and my aunt we don't really
talk to but my dad talks to them still
his brother and sister so
my dad was talking to my uncle
complaining about something about my
brother my uncle went and told his
daughter
by the way my sister was just hanging
out with my cousins out that way so as
my sister was coming home
my cousin calls my sister and goes hey
i heard your dad didn't go to the
doctor's my sister's like why are you
telling me my dad didn't go to the
doctor yeah well my dad said that your
dad said and started this whole baby
yeah when it was yes this whole big old
mess like it wasn't even just any other
business just about going because my dad
blamed my brother yeah
my dad blamed my brother for not going
to the doctors but then why does your
cousin have to get involved exactly
so why is this even worthy of a phone
call exactly so that's a whole thing so
but but what really happened was is that
my dad and my brother just something
ended up happening my dad didn't want to
go to the doctors but instead of saying
like
i just didn't go or not even telling his
brother
he put it on my brother
then he told his brother blaming his
nephew
then my uncle went and told his daughter
and then my cousin went told my sister
yeah and my sister's going what the [ __ ]
yeah what the hell is going on call's my
dad and it's like i don't want to be
playing the telephone game with you
anymore why did you tell our uncle
anything yeah and why am i hearing from
my cousin that you didn't go to the
doctors yeah families can get real messy
and this is a prime example of like
weird it just i don't know it's like i
think when you hit a certain age and
your family is like your friends and who
you are you know what i mean when your
family becomes your friends and who you
vent to yeah my uncle is a huge gossiper
it's like his favorite thing to do but
like my mom's like so my mom she's one
of she's one of nine kids okay so she
has lots of brothers and sisters and
that's that's that's how they are that's
how they are yeah and because of that
generation though
my generation their kids
don't want to be involved with the
family like we all
like because the brothers and sisters
are so tight like they ended up being
kind of really toxic and like their
whole
mess was like all the kids are like we
don't want to be a part of this yeah so
all of the cousins even though we were
tight because of our parents we distance
ourselves from our family because it's
like it's too messy there's too many
people there's too much drama like we
don't want to be involved with this yeah
it's where it makes sense
that's why i don't know them know them
yeah because all of us have the same
mentality as i do where i'm like i love
you but i don't want to be close to you
guys that's how i am with my sister and
brother we all have our own lives versus
how we were raised like if we if we
acted the way we were raised we'd all be
in the same house like all of us would
be living in the same house but so i
just so happen to have a conversation
with my sister she told me that all that
went down i was like okay
let me call my dad so then i ended up
calling dad and i kind of told him what
happened he was like you know what
that wasn't my intention and he goes it
does suck that i can't just talk to my
brother yeah because you know he's
raised us to be way more independent and
we all kind of you know hey you let me
know if i need to step in because i've
had to learn my boundaries with my
sister and brother too where i was a
little overbearing i was like okay
and i told him i was like look you can
go ahead and talk to your brother all
you want but at the moment you bring up
anybody else's name it's going to just
like have this weird effect because
they're all just still thriving off of
everyone else's failures so
to everybody that has those complicated
family situations you are not alone but
remember if you want to be an [ __ ]
own it
okay
so these are so good i don't can we need
two episodes of these because i really
like these these are so much fun
i love these because it's everyone
else's problem not mine right i'm just
applying
like just that first line [ __ ] not
the [ __ ] we vote and then by the end
of it we'll see if our decision stays
all right next one is make a little game
yeah
next one is would i be the [ __ ] if i
ask my pregnant wife to move out because
she and her best friend decided to test
my loyalty
okay what
here we go
so this is wait this is a hypothetical
situation he's thinking about doing it
thinking about telling her pregnant his
pregnant girlfriend to move out pregnant
wife to move out
because she and her best friend decided
to test my loyalty move out of where
does she live with the best friend no no
um
my wife like okay so he's the husband
yeah okay and the wife and him live
together yes um but then the wife and
her best friend decided to test his
loyalty so then he wants to kick her out
yeah of his house i guess so
let's see let's read the story we'll see
her their house okay so so right off the
bat i would say [ __ ] yeah
all right the story is my wife is
pregnant with our daughter initially we
were really happy and excited about it
but then she starts acting like a nut
job hormones hello but then she starts
acting like a nut job she gets angry and
irritated for small things insults me
when she doesn't like the food i make
starts acting insecure and accuses me of
losing attraction to her she's pregnant
i mean she that's still [ __ ] but but
still i mean it's kind of like what i
was saying earlier where it's like you
get a little bit of a pass because
you're under the influence of something
yeah just a little bit you can't go full
blown right right
you can't get out of hormones yeah you
can't get it fully excused
okay like she she won't like i don't
think she should get fully excused at
all not even half excuse like a quarter
excused okay
for example she wanted to eat chicken
sandwiches for dinner last week while i
made the chicken sandwiches
so she eats all the sandwiches leaves me
nothing and told me that they tasted
like [ __ ]
wow i wasn't pissed because she left me
nothing but if she didn't like them why
did she eat everything
when i asked her this she told me that
she was hungry okay fine she does this
every time eats everything i make and
calls it [ __ ]
i don't argue with her because i work
more than 80 hours a week and i really
want to have some peace when i come home
so
yesterday a random girl starts at
flirting with me after the gym and asked
me if i want to meet up with her for
some drinks i rejected her and i told
her that i was married when i got home
my wife started to hug me and apologize
when i asked her what happened she told
me that her best friend suggested a test
for my loyalty so they asked a mutual
friend to flirt with me and ask me out
and i passed yay i'm really pissed i'm
done with the antics would i be the
[ __ ] if i told her to move out
well
him asking her to move out is is he
asking for a divorce like what what's
the end game i don't know i want to know
what his end game is a separation for a
little bit
because she's being like that's not
she's being that's not cool that's not
all that's kind of like if someone got
cancer and like they have to take care
of them so much and then because of
everything they're going through they
end up being a lot
and then they're like you know what i
can handle you i'm out but that's like
that that's okay i can understand that
with stress of taking care of someone
but if someone's like testing you yeah
that's really shitty you're a loyalty
but also like insulting you that's super
shitty yeah yeah extra super [ __ ] yeah
testing your loyalty that she's messed
up yeah i don't know
i don't even want to give any
type of leeway to this one to go to that
extent you have to know once you cross
that line there's no going back yeah the
moment you have to test your partner
you're the relationship is over yeah
could you how would you feel if you got
tested exactly so say like say while you
were pregnant you you know you're doing
these things whatever and all of a
sudden like
you test your man yeah that's weird
especially because they're married too
already yeah yeah that's
too much so gross to be tested i
remember i went on a first date with
this one guy and we went to a restaurant
and he's like oh what are you going to
get i'm like i'm going to get this he
goes oh cool you passed the test i'm
like what test it goes you didn't order
the most expensive thing i was like
oh
like that is
yeah especially that's so
early yeah first testing me yeah that's
gross so i think in this situation you
write out the pregnancy you write it out
just because i feel like that's the
right thing to do you're you know you
guys are still technically married that
is still your child
don't give her a pass on this but
i i say that
after you guys need to have a
conversation of whether you're going to
stay together or not yeah i don't say
kick her out i say kicking arouse
probably not what you want to do
especially that would just make him an
[ __ ] yeah
yeah that's you know don't do that yeah
totally yes you would be an [ __ ] you
would be an [ __ ] if you kicked her
out but
i don't think you're wrong for wanting
to yeah to have that like thought i
don't think he's wrong yeah i feel like
the course of action that i would do in
his shoes is to seek therapy dude
because it's like you clearly have a lot
going on with your hormones you're
crossing lines like you can feel the way
you feel
you can't treat people
like this and also like our relationship
testing it we're married like
you're putting our relationship down the
gutter with this behavior and that that
is
some therapy that needs to be addressed
i feel like him jumping to kicking her
out is skipping a lot of steps yeah well
that's just a [ __ ] ton of steps yeah
that's the initial reaction though
that's like the knee-jerk reaction right
like
get the hell away from me look at all
the stuff i'm doing for you and this is
how you treat me but i mean he didn't
clearly he's at least getting an opinion
right yeah he hasn't done it yet he
hasn't done it yet so at least he's
weighing his options he's laying out his
options he's like look i don't like her
right now yeah and i'm not really you
can tell he's not an
[ __ ] yeah you can tell because the
fact that he's thinking about it and
hasn't done it
but damn girl
damn girl
sandwiches and
it's [ __ ]
i want to say it with you first off i
wouldn't want to kick her out there
exactly if i'm cooking you ain't gonna
leave me no food
she would have been gone then he's like
working 80 hours a week early and she's
just a [ __ ] to him he can cook yeah
girl he made you chicken sandwiches yeah
cause she said she wanted them too
that's so sweet you know how many girls
out here trying to get a bowl of cereal
you got chicken sandwiches and you will
eat them all
she does not have to be a [ __ ] so
top comment is not the [ __ ] yeah not
the [ __ ] not by a [ __ ] long shot
and i'm curious if anyone would be
justifying this that the genders were
reversed
you are absolutely not the [ __ ] and
being pregnant doesn't give you a blank
check to turn into a [ __ ] psychopath
your wife shouldn't be getting a pass on
this at the very minimum you need to
separate and go to counseling do you
really want to be dodging thirst traps
and mind games for the rest of your life
see this is why i think
i i think you'd be skipping a [ __ ] ton
of steps because if nothing else in the
relationship has ever been like this
before and that just tells me it's a
temporary hormonal situation that they
can just ride the wave it's not okay she
[ __ ] needs help she can't be doing
this
but is it really worth throwing away
your entire marriage and also the future
of your child having both their parents
yeah in your life right so if this is
like the first instance of some [ __ ]
up [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying like she gets
like a quarter of a pass because she's
hormonal she's under the influence like
she's not she's not sober she's not
herself yeah so i feel like fully
judging her and
just dismissing everything else like the
entire relationship over this
like small moment of time i think it's
really hasty to do yeah i mean the
question was would i be the [ __ ] if i
kicked out my wife yes you would be an
[ __ ] if you kicked out your wife if
the world were reversed that person
would be an [ __ ] too it doesn't
matter
you would be if you followed through
with it because you're jumping the gun
right you're missing out on all the
steps yeah but this comment is like no
and then separate well he didn't say
consider counseling yeah sure but
they're also suggesting separation where
it's like okay maybe you guys need your
space but like to fully separate yeah
she's pregnant i feel like it's too far
yeah well you know and that's what's
good about going through and hearing a
question versus just reading it right so
when you hear it you can paint the
picture we have the full scenario this
person is like they jumped the gun
because in reality
they're like no you wouldn't be but in
conclusion
you should probably not do it do you
know what i'm saying it's like their and
their initial reaction is like no if any
time somebody says if the rules were
reversed you've all the moment you say
that you you're you lost argument
because you're not you're looking at it
from like a different perspective you're
like you're already in your stance stay
on topic yeah yeah like you're just
you're trying to make it about something
that it's not the question is
would he be an [ __ ] if he kicked out
his pregnant wife
yes but
are you justified feeling this way
absolutely let's find a solution yeah
everyone is really torn on here because
there's a lot of people saying no she's
pregnant this one says
being pregnant doesn't give you a
license to abuse and gaslight people
asking or leave i think should be the
bare minimum
are probably
not like they have they're probably
young they haven't been married
they haven't been pregnant like they
don't understand the full scope of the
situation i feel like they're just going
based off of like
like yeah [ __ ] that she tested your
loyalty she's got to go [ __ ] the whole
marriage [ __ ] your child that's coming
into this world just do that like i am
just so
short-sighted so he's saying i'm not
talking about divorce just some time
apart
oh that's different yeah
oh yeah a separation yeah yeah i i mean
i personally still feel like that's too
far
even though yeah she's being a [ __ ] i
fully agree she's fully being an [ __ ]
absolutely i don't think it's
i feel like he'd be
he wouldn't be giving his marriage the
care that it needs to just throw it away
like that just because he he's like
you're too much i can't handle you
instead of like
okay you're a lot right now we need to
work through this we need to talk about
this you're pushing me to the edge we
need to work on this together this is
not okay
here here's like here's my [ __ ] foot
this is not okay i love you though we're
gonna work through this that's different
let's talk about this best friend who is
dodging the bullet right now yeah people
are saying people let's talk about this
ratchet trash
your best friend is trash girl
your best friend she ain't pregnant yeah
she helps you with this whole [ __ ]
you've been waiting for an opportunity
to [ __ ] wreck this marriage off top
that friendship is over yeah like as far
as the way that this marriage and and
the friendship goes she chose her friend
over her husband
that right there is the that that is
what happened her friend was in her ear
she's already hormonal she's already not
doing well her friend is sitting over
here yeah
causing drama the biggest thing is that
he needs to say
i hate the ultimatum but i would have no
problem saying it's either me or your
best friend because she
she is trying to sabotage your behavior
i agree with that yeah i would i would
agree with you people are in the
comments saying yeah that best friend is
absolute [ __ ] yeah that isn't a best
friend no yes girl you ain't got no no
no you can come step right up and catch
these hands too
because where is she gonna go with the
best friend what's the best friend going
to do is going to tell her that she
doesn't deserve the way that he's
treating her she's going to be the
reason why the relationship isn't going
to work yeah we all know some of some
people out there got some hate and ass
best friends
that be on the low dropping all these
little things in your ear making you
feel some type of way and the next thing
you know you're single and they're
single and you're like oh my god oh yeah
are you suffering together right you
know what it can be hard to fit
everything in especially when it comes
to luggage with bays there's room for
everything even if you're an overpacker
which i 1000 m i am also traveling with
a six month old and that requires a lot
of things but luckily my entire luggage
system is based and i'm completely in
love with it i have the check-in i have
the carry-on i have the mini weekender
and i also have the dopp kit i also for
my family like my husband he has a
check-in and my son has the regular big
weekender like we're a full base family
in this household big big fans like this
luggage is such good quality and really
they've thought of everything there's
pockets for everything and it makes your
stuff look aesthetically beautiful too
as you're traveling i love it i'm a huge
fan so baze was created by actress shea
mitchell to make sleek and affordable
bags luggage and accessories designed to
help you travel effortlessly while still
looking fashionable base has thought of
everything you could ever want in a
piece of luggage 360 degree gliding
wheels a cushioned handle
built-in weight indicator washable bags
for your dirty clothes and all the
interior pockets you need to keep
organized there's also this really cool
feature that i really love about the
bayes luggage is like i don't know what
they exactly call it but there's this
thing that you kind of pull out like a
string thing that allows you to connect
another bag to it so you don't have to
haul all your bags together like they
could kind of connect to each other you
know what check out their website
they'll explain way better than i did
their luggage comes in multiple sizes
and colors and for shorter trips the
weekender bag is super functional and it
even has a place to store your shoes
separately it's under the bag so
convenient keeps your clothes nice and
clean i love it every piece is made to
look better with miles so you don't have
to worry about it in cargo or overhead
and base has over thirty thousand
five-star reviews whether you're packing
for a quick trip or looking to breeze
through the security line baze has your
personal items covered right now base is
offering our listeners 15 off your first
purchase by visiting
baystravel.com big mode go to
baystravel.com big mood for 15 off your
first purchase that's b e i s travel dot
com slash big mood okay
next one god these are so much fun
i love these
emma the [ __ ] for not waking up my
girlfriend for her exam after i
overheard her calling me a little [ __ ]
hmm
okay here we go
let's dive right in
my girlfriend has online summer courses
and she had an exam for one of them this
morning
i usually wake her up for pretty much
everything because she sleeps through
her phone alarm no matter how long it
buzzes or how many she sets
she has joked that i'm her butler before
and within the context of her shift it's
okay so i don't mind obviously i want to
love my partner and try to make her life
easy okay clearly he minds
however i would too
last night she was chatting with her
friends and she thought i couldn't hear
she was bragging that i'm her little
[ __ ] and i do everything for her when
she tells me to
it really hurt my feelings because they
were making comments like good put him
in his place and she was agreeing oh
she specifically said yeah i'm not
worried about tomorrow because the [ __ ]
will make sure i'm up and he'll probably
have breakfast ready for me too oh girl
girl i went to bed pretty hurt by it
[Applause]
my heart sank to my stomach right now
that sucks how can someone be so cruel i
feel so bad for this guy yeah i went to
bed pretty hurt by it and come morning i
didn't bother to wake her up when her
alarm started to go
she usually only gets up when someone
physically shakes her but i let her turn
off her like the [ __ ] she requires
physically being shook some people are
really yeah no but like for him to do
that every morning every morning right
[ __ ]
um but i let her turn off her alarm and
she slipped back into sleep and turned
around and i went back to sleep too
when she woke up she was yelling at me
saying i'm an [ __ ] and i've cost her
her exam and i'm a piece of [ __ ] for
what i did
um and then we can discuss but he also
has an update so do you want to hear the
update first you want to discuss first
discussion yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] you
ain't not the [ __ ] goodbye [ __ ] you
are not the [ __ ] but if you are still
with her you're stupid yes
you are not the [ __ ] but you're a
dummy if you end up staying with her
yeah she is so mean how can you say that
about someone he oh you he must have
been in love for babies
poor baby
i wonder how long they've been together
like how long has this been going on
where and then she's
talking to her friends is what he
overheard yeah yeah damn so the friends
also see him like
oh damn that sucks yeah i'm glad you let
her sleep good for you that's crazy okay
i need the update because they better
not be together top comments are
basically not the [ __ ] your
girlfriend sounds incredibly abusive you
shouldn't have to put up with that don't
wait for any more red flags get out of
this now you guys are better so update
he said um sorry for not responding
sooner i wrote this up on my break at
work and now i have to get back to
work um can have my phone you know i
wasn't expecting this many reply so fast
update i think we're breaking up i told
her this morning after she called me a
[ __ ] for being upset for not waking her
up and she was being a [ __ ] but she
says she's not done with me
what i'm just trying to get through i
don't want to be done either i'm just
trying to get through today's shift and
then deal with the stuff later i'll try
and get back as soon as i can we've been
together a year
and it was my first real relationship oh
damn girl you're not ruining a good one
right
that sucks he's so nice we've been
looking for the nice ones right it's my
first relationship but i'm tired of her
not acknowledging how shitty she made me
feel and still call me a [ __ ] this word
is really making me feel like [ __ ] and
very small dang love breakup with her
you do not deserve this she is going to
keep playing on your insecurities you
she's feeding off of it i just so mean i
just hope that you don't change who you
are because of her like
forget what everybody says about the
nice guys finish last no you just found
the wrong girl this is not your girl
there's going to be somebody that is
going to appreciate you that is going to
love all those things about you and that
you are going to make very happy and
therefore will you call you her butler
yeah jeez yeah no that's what i'm called
for this is
maybe you are so much better than her
there are just things words
like things that you do things that you
say that you never ever ever ever see in
a relationship you never cross that line
yeah no matter how angry you are
whenever i argue or whenever i'm upset
i don't call someone that i never cuss
at them i don't even say yo [ __ ] this
[ __ ] and [ __ ] that like i never say that
i don't like i sure as i don't call
anyone a [ __ ] like that is just
rude like that's cruel because i feel
like in like i'm sure we all agree in a
relationship you should always choose
kindness even when you're angry you
still have to be kind to each other you
don't just straight up just be like hey
[ __ ] you you stupid [ __ ] or this guy's
a [ __ ] whatever you never saw you never
call someone that yeah that's just a
lack of respect yeah and you should
never be with someone like that the poor
guy it's his first relationship i know
how old is he
sounds really young i mean they're like
probably in their early 20s yeah
probably probably early 20s but yeah you
first off i'm glad you didn't wake her
up because she needed a taste of her own
medicine yeah but if you stay you are
subjecting yourself to just be treated
like [ __ ] for sure you're doing it to
yourself the fact that he says i think
we're breaking up and it's like oh poor
baby yeah you need it
yeah that's really that's so shitty i
wonder like
i wonder if this is like how she is and
all her relationships totally well
that's probably the types of guys she
goes for yeah you know she loves being
catered
you can like being catered to but still
respect that person yeah and that's a
relationship to where somebody is very
loving and giving and somebody likes to
receive but you don't turn around and
call them a like you're a butler or your
[ __ ] abusive and all her friends agree
with it well first off she's trash so
we're friends yeah but all her friends
probably would date you in a heartbeat
just let you know oh yeah all her
friends would die to have you absolutely
that's really shitty poor baby i feel
the heartbreak through
the words like how he writes it like how
he's just like oh you know send us your
send us your profile we'll find you
someone better or something
yeah you get that
i'll show you a little kitty nipple too
if you like that depends what you're
into
so funny
we're gonna but
her leave her leave her i can't find his
profile to see if there's any updates um
he deleted his profile but i really hope
he left her and you guys should never
ever be with anyone like that no no no
matter how nice they are to you or they
buy you nice things or they do things
for you if they're talking about you
like that yeah to anyone or to you or
whatever that is not okay ever ever ever
ever you don't deserve that oh my god
yeah everyone deserves respect mm-hmm
okay
let's squeeze in one last one okay um am
i the [ __ ] if i stop paying my
daughter's tuition after a disgusting
comment she made towards my girlfriend
get him daddy okay
he is so the person speaking he is a 56
year old male okay he said my wife died
at the young age of 51 from a car
accident i was in deep mourning for
about a year after her death i met my
new girlfriend 43 year old female around
january we'll call her c c was the one
who made me laugh for the first time
after my wife died she's smart as hell
three ivy league degrees wow
he uh has a dark sense of humor that i
love a terrific cook and overall an
amazing woman who i can imagine spending
the rest of my life with she's also on
the heavier side a fact that becomes
relevant later oh boy
oh god i have two children
25 male a 25 year old male will call him
e
and a 19 year old daughter will call her
a so 25 year old son e daughter a 19.
they were well aware that i had gotten a
new girlfriend before i first introduced
them to c this summer she got along
immediately with my son e but my
daughter a was very very standoffish
after the initial meeting i asked a if
there was something wrong but she denied
it
c made a few more attempts to get to
know a but they were all rudely rejected
my son and daughter ena both came home
from came home for thanksgiving dinner i
asked abe to please be polite during the
meal since she's always been rude in her
interactions with my girlfriend even
though my girlfriend has been nothing
but gracious in return the dinner was
going well as it could have been for the
first 10 minutes although i noticed a
glaring at my girlfriend the whole
entire time
when my girlfriend went to grab her
third helping of mashed potatoes my
daughter said don't you think you've
eaten enough you fat pig whoa
oh my god
i know baby i know
i was like what
my girlfriend started sobbing
immediately and ran off into the bedroom
oh that's so sad i felt my face turned
red and told my daughter to get out
about a half an hour after my daughter
left i texted her stating that i would
no longer pay her tuition unless one she
apologizes to my girlfriend and two my
girlfriend accepts her apology she must
have assumed that i was bluffing because
she's instead doubled down on her
behavior during thanksgiving dinner what
is her reasoning like how does
i know the
subconscious
reasons what is her conscious reason
like what is she even saying like why
i then logged into her university's
tuition payment website canceled next
semester's tuition and sent my daughter
to screenshots she called me crying and
begging me to reconsider but i told her
my mind was made up am i the [ __ ] no
no no she's old enough to make her own
tuition the fact that you gave her an
ultimatum yeah all you had to do was
apologize yeah get your priorities
straight yeah you want to go you want to
be an [ __ ] you think you're big and
bad and you want to talk this smack then
guess what you're an adult now
you have to learn that lesson it's a
hard lesson you're gonna have to learn
and you put it on yourself yeah you
can't be a dick like that especially
when you're depending on someone yeah
don't bite the hand that feels no
especially when the woman hasn't done
anything wrong my dad's favorite saying
is you're only a man until you can pay
your own bills you are not grown until
you can pay your own bills so guess what
you always have someone to answer to all
she had to do was apologize
the girlfriend would have accepted it
because she wants you to like her yeah
exactly she's going to but then doubling
down yo shout out to the dad and to the
parents out there not letting their kids
just run all over them yeah like you got
to teach them some damn respect because
this is the lesson that's going to like
make her a better person yeah if he
would have like not cancelled the
tuition she's going to run she's going
to run around and make somebody's life a
living hell hell yeah yeah that's
[ __ ] horrible i can't believe like
she had the balls to even save that
disrespect yeah to someone who's been
nothing but nice and gracious trying to
get in good with her like okay yeah you
can be hurt that your mom is gone you
can be heard that your dad's moving on
there's no reason to be cruel yeah like
that's so [ __ ] up even i got over the
whole like oh my parents are divorced
and they're not in love with more my dad
has a new girlfriend i got over that
when i was like
11. this girl is 19 and in college you
have to understand that his new
girlfriend is taking good care of him
making him happy because you're off to
college and your brother like you guys
can't be there she's old enough to
understand that yeah and like she hasn't
done like the woman hasn't done anything
wrong so she's a [ __ ] yeah everybody
you know grieves differently but girl
you had your chance mm-hmm you could
have just said freaking sorry you don't
have to like the woman and now you're in
debt now yeah
see now you gotta pay interest right
right now you gotta get a job look all
you had to do was say sorry
you dumb dumb the fact that she couldn't
do it but then went in more yo you
tested your dad yep and he showed you
who was in charge you [ __ ] around now
you're eating now you're eating top
ramen and going on youtube trying to
figure out 62 different ways to make
with one packet mm-hmm and you're more
now then you're gonna get scurvy because
that's what happens when you eat too
much ramen i didn't know that i didn't
know that wait wait what what about you
read about it on what i read about
scurvy because i literally survived off
of that three whole childhood
we're all over here looking at marx and
we're like that explains a lot it's a
disease caused by the deficiency of
vitamin c characterized by swollen
bleeding gums
and the eggs and the opening of
previously healed wounds
you know why i didn't get scurvy because
i [ __ ] love limes and lemons there
you go i was going to say all the
vitamin c yeah compensate you just
squeeze a whole bunch of lime juice
inside of your raw mango you don't get
scurvy that's the only way i would eat
it college hack
oh that's oh you put it in your round
that's awesome yeah yeah i didn't know
that you could have ramen different ways
i grew up only eating it with lime and
tapatio that's the only way i ever ate
it my whole life crispy noodles you can
make crispy noodles out of your ramen oh
crocodile recipes for you so are we
agreeing he's not the [ __ ] no top
comment is everyone sucks here yeah no
weird no for sure that for sure the
daughter
is a major [ __ ] i don't think the
girlfriend is where the [ __ ] is she an
[ __ ] wait they said everyone's an
[ __ ] here everyone sucks here
something more is undoubtedly going on
between your girlfriend and your
daughter you need to find out why your
daughter has such a strong dislike of
her and reacts so strongly your daughter
is still deep in mourning for her mother
okay we know that you've managed to put
your grief behind you but the process is
getting is much slower for some people
seeing your girlfriend in her mother's
place at thanksgiving was probably very
hard for your daughter that doesn't
excuse her rudeness but it might explain
it secondly you've made your daughter's
tuition dependent on your girlfriend
accepting her apology as the fees are
something between you and your daughter
that's not appropriate especially as the
girlfriend seems to be the issue here
what
no your daughter is being a damn brat
you brought your daughter's being a
little [ __ ] and what you did was
finally put her in her place you
disciplined your daughter all you have
to do is apologize if you don't want to
apolog if you don't want to apologize
then go and be an adult elsewhere it's
that simple when a bank tells you oh if
you want this money all you got to do is
this you're not going to tell the bank
no right you're going to do what you got
to do to get that money i really wanted
to i wonder how long
after the mother passed that he start
dating this woman
did you say here yeah yeah okay look and
i wonder how long he's been dating this
new woman see she can be mad all she
wants no one's taking that away but girl
if you want your tuition paid you play
your freaking part i could see what this
commenter is saying though because
they're saying like the
punishment doesn't fit the crime if it's
his money yes it does it's his money
it's his rules
yeah i agree too i agree but i can see
kind of like what they're trying to get
at where it's like now you're bringing
your girlfriends feelings into
your financial situation agreement that
you have with your daughter with her
with her education i get where they're
going
but i still i i still agree it's like
you gotta teach your daughter a lesson
somehow and if this is a way that
is going to make her listen and make her
learn then that's just the route that
you have to take i mean [ __ ] what else
do you do as a parent if he's not if
she's not living under his roof
and but he is providing her roof by
paying her tuition like
i
i'm not like this is a muscle that i'm
trying to exercise better with my own
kids where it's like how do you
match
like what like the punishment to the
crime kind of thing because like for
example when isaac is being
disrespectful
um it depends on what he says or what
he's doing but usually my go-to is like
okay well you
have been disrespectful now you no
longer get to have a privilege and a
privilege
is your phone i pay for your phone
now give me your phone because now
you're you're no longer going to have
this privilege because now you're taking
advantage of uh
of a situ you're being disrespectful
and there's no reason for you to
continue to get
uh praised or rewarded with this
privilege when you're being
disrespectful that's kind of how my
thought process is but i know that
there's probably other ways like other
things i could do to better educate him
which is something i'm trying to
like i said i'm exercising this muscle
because i can't quickly think of like
when if he talks back to me like what is
an appropriate response to that other
than removing the phone because the
phone has nothing to do with that moment
that he talked back to me so i
understand where this commenter is
coming from yeah so so
uh one of the top comments says
yeah the punishment just doesn't seem to
fit the crime oh you called my new
girlfriend a fat pig so i'm gonna
completely [ __ ] over your entire planned
future i don't see how you could think
that this will lessen the resentment
towards a new girlfriend either now
she's in a position where she won't be
able to get a job and save enough to
make it through school thus condemning
her to either drop out or take massive
loans both options seriously negatively
impact her future and likely would
prevent her from maturing beyond the
person she is now as somebody that was
reliant on other people for a lot of my
upbringing
you follow the [ __ ] rules i do not
care if somebody is giving you money and
you have rules that you have to abide by
in order to get this money you are going
to follow the rules to get the money as
somebody who needed it you know your
place no one to speak and no one not to
you do that so you can get in a position
to not ever have to do that again you
are subservient to your father and his
money it's his rules you were you were
taught that that lesson growing up
clearly she wasn't yeah yeah and now
she's getting that lesson and other
people would argue well it's [ __ ] up
her whole life she didn't get this
lesson but now she has to get it where
it's going to affect her whole future
yeah but i think that like i can hear
that side but
i'm happy i learned that lesson early
because let me tell you if i'm giving
you money
and you go and disrespect i don't care
if it matches or not it's my money
i can go and put my money elsewhere i
got you to the place to where you're an
adult you are 19 years old
all you had to do was say sorry yeah
because in life you're gonna have to do
things you don't want to do a lot
a lot
i i feel both sides man i really do
because i can see her sides like she can
grow to resent him and be like
he put
his girlfriend
before me yeah and now look at my life
and whatever all because i called her a
fat [ __ ] i mean but get the [ __ ] over
you're an adult i called you fab [ __ ]
get over it but couldn't she go and take
that moment and realize but also i
screwed myself over because i called her
a [ __ ] all i had to do was say 19 year
old ego is not yeah
so how does she learn because if she's
doing this now she's going to do it in
the future this sounds like the type of
girl that's going to just feel entitled
to everything and will probably be in
and out of jobs regardless because she
feels entitled yeah that anger and and
entitlement and resentment is just going
to grow with how she's already handling
it
so
yeah like there there must be i don't
know what the way is there must be a
better way for this dad
you know maybe there's an opportunity
here that she now can respect the fact
that he will follow through with his
word that you can go ahead and have a
conversation with her to where it's like
look now we have to establish some rules
take the girlfriend out of the situation
lay out some ground rules and say she
has to abide by them and then she can
get the money i think that there is
still
a way they can salvage this to where he
respects
not respects it to where she respects
her father
remove the girlfriend he can still help
her but there has to be some damn ground
rules
they need to discuss this they do
apologize and get that money just
apologize hey [ __ ] it's all right we say
sorry all the time and i don't mean it
no
learn how to i am so sorry
i won't do it again
see how easy that was
all right i think that's the end of this
episode that was fun yeah
i'm gonna do more of these thank you
guys for watching leave your opinions
below on each story because i want to
hear we want to hear your opinion on
this because these
these were interesting yeah man i love
poking my nose into other people's
business because there's still so many
different perspectives from all of them
and nothing happens to me that's so
awesome i love it
thank you for watching myself like that
i end up like putting myself in each
situation where i'm like i know i've
been an [ __ ] like that i know i've
yeah i've been in that situation like so
where are you judging people no
consequences
thanks for watching um make sure you
guys check out our sponsors follow us
below and of course follow our beautiful
guest here nikki blades
and we will see you guys next week we
love you bye check out our stuff in the
description love you bye
[Music]
you